welcome back everybody we're going to be
Switching gears right now to St John's
County Florida where the mother of
convicted murderer Aiden fucci is
gearing up for trial because she's
accused of helping her son cover up the
horrific death of a young cheerleader
two years ago on Mother's Day 13 year
old Tristan Bailey was found stabbed 114
times with part of the murder weapon
weapon broken off in her skull fucci was
arrested the next day and charged as an
adult with first degree murder Fuji's
mother Crystal Smith faces an Evidence
tampering charge and that is because
according to Smith's arrest warrant and
affidavit video surveillance shows her
going into Fuji's bedroom and scrubbing
a pair of blood-soaked jeans in the
bathroom sink it's allegedly the same
pair of jeans that Fuji had on when he
stabbed Bailey to death Smith faces up
to five years in prison if she's
convicted her trial is set to start on
the 17th now in case you missed how
Aidan Fuji sentencing panned out last
month his penalty phase lasted four days
the prosecution argued that Fuji told
his closest friends he planned to murder
someone ahead of time in the same way he
killed Bailey fucci's defense team
emphasized the fact that he was 14 years
old at the time of the murder and said
he's entitled to a reduced sentence
because of the law well when all said
when all was said and done judge R Lee
Smith sentenced fucci to the maximum
amount for his age life in prison with a
sentence review after 25 years Bailey's
Family had an opportunity to address
Fuji at that sentencing hearing here's
part of what they had to say
I want to be clear
saying that you're insincere apology is
not accepted
and no part did I sense any glimmer of
any true remorse
felt in your apology without question I
know that statement was for some
self-serving purpose that you have I
loathe your very existence and know that
there is nothing within you that
reflects the smallest amount of goodness
or human decency 114.
yeah
this jar now holds 114 Stones one for
each of the 114 stab wounds that my
sister had to endure last one is
it represents everything that you have
stolen from me my words my Joys my hope
my future and my beautiful daughter
that's always how horrible to see so
Terry talk about the mother what exactly
does the prosecution have to prove to
support a tampering with evidence charge
in Florida you know it's not as easy as
you may think first of all they have to
prove that she was knowing and
intentionally doing this that she knew
there were some pending charges or a
pending investigation that she
manipulated that evidence and she
altered it and also that she wanted to
change the outcome of the case and so to
do all of that they're going to have to
show that when she went in that room and
she picked up those jeans and she did
the wash that she knew he was being
investigated or he was being charged or
there was going to be a trial and that
she was trying to alter that evidence so
he wouldn't be held responsible for the
case so they're going to have to show
some intent there and it might be
difficult to say exactly what she knew
and when she learned about what happened
Mike the problem is if she's seen on
tape washing the jeans if you have that
that video you heard Terry explaining
maybe some of the difficulties how do
you really defend against that
well I think Terry gave an excellent
excellent explanation of how complicated
it really becomes when you break it down
step by step
I mean number one is this is the child's
mother
so it is not unusual to have a mother
cleaning someone's clothes we're gonna
add blood on it or not would have to be
proven that she knew where the blood
came from if he said I was playing and
my friend got a bloody nose or something
like that we don't have any proof or we
don't know of any right now so there has
to be a connection
um sometimes people think pictures speak
a thousand words they don't in a
courtroom unless you can really solidify
and prove Beyond A Reasonable Doubt what
they're displaying all right I
still think this is a tough case for the
defense but hey that's my two cents
we'll see which way it goes when we come
back fans of the hit HBO show The Wire
still mourn the loss of Michael K
Williams now the dealer responsible for
his deadly drug combination is facing
some serious prison time that's next
[Music]
thank you
we're finishing Today's Show right here
in New York City where a drug dealer
pleaded guilty this week to giving a
well-known actor the substance that
ultimately killed him Michael K Williams
was known for his role as Omar little on
the HBO series The Wire he died in
September of 2021 of a drug overdose at
the age of 54. nearly two years after
William's death Irvin Cartagena known as
the street Nate or known by the street
name green eyes pleaded guilty to drug
distribution charges in Manhattan
federal court video surveillance
captures the moment Cartagena handed
Williams heroin laced with fentanyl one
of the leading causes of overdoses in
the United States Williams was found
unresponsive in his Brooklyn apartment
just a day later Cartagena is one of
several co-conspirators arrested in the
case but is the first one to plead
guilty he's facing a mandatory sentence
of 5 to 40 years in prison Mike really
really sad case here now the argument
could be made though right that
Cartagena only sold Williams the drugs I
mean what happened to them afterwards
was it really his business I mean what
do you have to say to that
well it's a it's a it's not as a
difficult the case to prove federally
and this is a federal case because it's
mostly a strict liability case where if
they could prove the cause of death was
related to drugs now he there's a time
lapse here but I assume they probably
had confiscated some drugs on the dealer
and maybe found some drugs in the
packaging in the apartment of the victim
and therefore there is a lot of
circumstantial evidence that could show
hopefully for the government that there
is proof Beyond a reasonable doubt that
those were the drugs that were purchased
that he overdosed on
you know Terry there's something to be
said he takes this plea deal you know
maybe stack it takes away the kind of
the pain of a trial and things like that
but do you think the sentence that
Cartagena will actually get is going to
be on the higher or the lower end in
terms of years because just because you
plead guilty doesn't mean you're always
going to get leniency right well that's
right he can't really predict what's
going to happen he can only hope that he
gets on the lighter side but I think
they're going to do it on the greater
side he's facing a minimum of five years
maximum of 40 and I think they're going
to lean towards that 40. first of all we
know that opioid use is really a crisis
here in the United States and I do think
they're going to try to send a message
the other issue is this drug dealer
Cartagena he knew that there was a death
he knew that Williams died and even
after that he continued to sell the
drugs so even if you argue that he
didn't realize it was going to cause the
death there's still the issue of the
fact that he continued to sell and I
think they want to send a message that
if you're selling these types of drugs
and there's a possibility that they
could be laced with fentanyl you're
going to face as much as you can here
because we want people to stop doing
exactly that so setting an example I
hear that all right Mike Terry thank you
both so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign
thank you